Ramos we're just going to do one camera
today that's okay with you guys
hello everybody I've done a cooking
video to wobble let me tell you what I
have done in many videos is wear this
shirt I'm have two of them if anyone
wants to go back and count how many
times I've worn this shirt in videos I'm
just worth the other day what you should
do is give a close-up of this pathetic
box not even in a video or what well I
don't know I don't have a microphone
here lo use are you you yeah your guess
when you look at this box what do you
think I think of goosebumps Nickelodeon
it's packaged like we might not wait
this is this you can add that tape no a
game like this where did you get work
you're doing wait wait there's another
bag inside this ass open I wouldn't
where did you get it
Internet from Amazon do you think you
ordered cake better on Amazon see
officer Nick Carter on the front of it
camouflage cupcakes okay that's pretty
cool actually do a good job and make
these taste good because I would love a
cupcake right now okay we might not
actually making any cupcakes depending
upon what's inside here I think we're
gonna be good do you think you want to
pull my knife you have a knife no I've
got chapstick I was like well show me
when I feel ox I'll show you my knife
you're good oh oh that's pretty secure
yeah I think we're okay yeah we're good
what's this this drove a bag of drugs
wait that's it okay that's up and that's
not the oven hold on Oh Who I am do you
even how to work those atoms yes what
you now know how to turn on the other oh
there is I don't have to worry about the
ZT y cv y okay that's the color
indicator okay
where's the pot and then I need to get
those out I need three eggs
shouldn't you button everything out
already yeah reason this right
everywhere you want we're get our
crowning yes we will take those how many
do you think we're making cupcakes
divide the batter into four so what
makes an egg organic because they don't
feed the chickens hormones or they feed
them all organic food
oh just welcome to the jungle
you really just went for it there you
know beat two minutes
we ain't beat nothing I'll put this in
this bowl on mixing it doesn't look
camouflage
well that's because we've got a food
this was nice kuqali
you know much sugar is in this one thing
tell us 294 Ramsey bad I thought it'd be
worse what the whole cab ice like me and
Jenna beaten one of those by ourselves
now mix this sad just luck you should
right now mix it good eat that I said
lucky lighten some good okay oh boy
so things are going well are you done
yes I do everything else opposed to do
yeah my question so where's the
camouflage get to Megan's that's why we
have four bowls do we what happened I
got another question yeah your buddy
rubble in her yeah you did I don't think
you do anymore I think someone drank it
all thanks Steve drinker you drink it
you can try coffee for the first time
woo that's why through this
oh you're fat you holding it there okay
so 1/8 tsp green and 1/8 tsp brown green
and brown and one art green green brown
another one you do just green and just
brown I'm not following either what did
you put in here just great okay they're
not just green but brown and that is but
I put a lot of green in there okay all
right everybody grab a bowl I'll start
mixing soon thanks for being in my video
guys I'm sorry Nick um this looks not
not well okay this is great
good this is a lot easier three people I
know right see Martin is phenomenal
all right now you put them in the oven
there's old times it's getting hot in
here so take off your clothes nice cam
thank you
Hugh were gone we shot another video and
we use one of the cupcakes for it so
apologies that video is probably posted
on Jenna's channel like five months ago
yes it's a good video here we go we've
got the cakes let's wash your hands
everybody we're gonna show them the case
you have to wash your hands first are
they children settled in the cakes whoa
it looks cool that looks awesome
actually let me see it let's put some
icing on these and do a taste test okay
if this is how I go down this is my
demise you mean
Oh cupcakes that box was so shady you
should never eat something like that but
I'm gonna do it anyway I don't know how
many eaten it is to be honest just take
a look at the page whoever in this looks
you're eating not a cupcake oh my gosh
gosh you're so healthy which is really
good ah my chicken tastes like vo my pop
grows like a cupcake anyway thanks for
watching guys ever watch Seinfeld top of
the muffin mom no but this is really
good and I can't control myself once
I've started well I'm not gonna try I'm
trying to watch my sugar intake yeah I
got my ball and you're watching it and
go into my mouth
thank you for watching check out another
Channel I can't stop oh oh you mean this
somebody I just did what wait check out
my channel that's you toasted well you
got nade didn't you know it's nadeshot
everybody never saw cupcake it's not
there anymore in there Ronald wads no
job
round of applause baby make that clap
drop it to the foe make that ass clap oh
my god
like it just taste it state the top I
whole thing if I don't make it and this
night that's it look I'm gonna bite on
come on I don't mean my dinner right now
you're right yeah yeah you're so healthy
hey guys happy I've had pearl launch day
I'm pretty pumped ordered it last night
at midnight and now we're gonna go get
some breakfast and then pick it up and
wait for the Apple store to open
Maddy's gonna have a fun day today